okay let's have a look at uh question 11
all right now first i'm just going to
put up my equation i didn't check it
against the answers i just did it
so someone want to tell me if this is
what
you got that's what i landed on
that's a relief okay this is 11. this is
the very first question
yeah that's the final line you should
end up on hands up hands up
hmm
another another hand up this time who
had a diagram again same question
okay at least we had to start there keep
your hand up if your diagram this is you
now not the
paper you're marking hands up if your
diagram was a coordinate set of axes
okay interesting so that was like less
than half the people all right let's
have a go at this again there's a lot to
unpack here right
the corner center axis really helps is
my suggestion okay i'll show you what
mine looks like in a second
so let's start off it says they give you
a vertex i'm just going to start writing
this down because i don't even know
where to fit it all together until i've
got a lot of it
all in one go so they give you this is
question 11. uh
3 negative 1 3 negative one isn't it
they give you a vertex
they say a vertex is just a corner right
it's of a rectangle
rectangle abcd what's the other thing
they tell you about abcd
yeah they gave you the equations of one
of the sides which side was it is it a
d d so its equation is what again
uh 2x minus y minus 7
minus 7 equals zero fantastic okay now
i'm curious how many of you looked at
this and thought oh i know exactly what
to do
yeah one two fantastic well done you're
ahead of me i looked at this and i was
like
i really was not sure where to start and
that's why i started drawing okay
so everything oops where's it going
everything that we can see here we can
start to fit onto a diagram now as i
walked around
i saw a few rectangles that's a good
start okay but you can see there's so
much coordinate geometry stuff here
the cartesian plane will really help you
okay so if you haven't
already uh draw yourself a cartesian
plane
okay now uh this is probably the most
important like the most useful thing to
me two x minus y minus seven equals
zero general forms not heaps easy to
graph though
yeah let's let's do exactly that okay so
it gets presented to us like this
but my brain is quite good at graphing
not this form but
uh gradient intercept form so if i add y
to both sides i end up with
this is that okay so we're pretty good
at knowing what that's supposed to look
like we know it's gradient we know it's
y intercept so let's go ahead and draw
that
something like that you're content with
that i've got a y intercept down
here and i also have you can work out
what the x-intercept is if you like
okay uh
yeah three and a half yep cool
so there's a d and then i also know that
a
is is going to be somewhere on this line
right that's line a d so three comma
negative one
um even if i've drawn a pretty rough
diagram you can see oh that's just a bit
before here
do you see that if that's three and a
half three is just a smidge before that
so you're like there we go three
negative one that's
that's a okay
so far so good is that right now this is
a d
where's d by the way
somewhere on that line you don't even
know but that tells you
i guess i don't need to know but it's
it's somewhere along there now i put it
somewhere just so i could get a handle
on where this thing would go
because now i've got this rectangle abcd
that i've got to sort of fit around this
okay now where is b
i don't know but the thing about a
rectangle is
all the sides meet at all the sides made
at what
90 degrees that's what rectangle means
right angled okay
so therefore there's going to be some
perpendicular line through here
b is going to sit somewhere on that is
that okay maybe it's over here
maybe it's here maybe it's there it
doesn't matter the equation would still
fit all of those
so if b was here i know there's a right
angle
right so if it's perpendicular what can
i get from that
it's ryan you were doing a question like
this just yesterday i think what can we
know about its gradients
go ahead
fantastic so i know this gradient it's
going to be 2.
right so therefore i can already infer
if the gradients multiplied together to
give negative 1
then the gradient i want gradient a b
is negative a half fantastic i've got a
gradient
i only need one other piece of
information to know the equation which
is
what else do i know about this now this
y intercept interestingly i actually
don't um
i could probably eventually work it out
but there's a more direct piece of
knowledge i have access to zacky
nicely done yeah a b has to pass through
a
right in fact me drawing it kind of
tells me that it's got to go through
this point 3 comma
negative 1. you can go ahead and i won't
do the working because i think you can
work it out from here and put it into
point gradient form point gradient form
looks like this
x plus 2y minus negative half
have i done something wrong i'm no no so
where did you get negative half from
should i start using working to unpack
it so for example
so you're starting to unpack this guy
here yeah yes yes yep
okay so let me start to ah you tell me
at what point i can stop okay
i'm gonna start substituting this into
here so
i'm really super suspicious of myself
and the negatives that are all gonna fly
around
so instead of doing any resolution of
those negatives i'm literally gonna
write
minus and then there's my y1 okay with
that
so there's a double negative already
here comes another negative what a
jerk of a question there's the gradient
and then i've got x minus three out
there
is that okay is that okay there's my
m x minus x one
so at least you got to that that's
really important you've done a whole lot
of work what was this worth again
is it two okay i reckon you might have
something there because you've done a
lot of the leg work
okay um is that still looking okay
though zacky for you
now this is important right just like in
question
12 this one you know how it's like oh
exact value i know where i'm headed
so therefore that informs my working i
start doing this immediately
in the same way this question they
already tell us how they want their
final answer what form do they want in
general general form right so the first
thing i do here
is i want to get rid of my fractions
general form doesn't have fractions in
it that's kind of one of the
points of it right so immediately
my next thing is i'm going to get rid of
that by multiplying through by 2
because then everything's in whole
numbers does that make sense so there
will not be any
halves or anything like that flying
around here something else has happened
though if these are right
for you and this is still a fraction so
yeah